[Music]
was it really all about a dog
what's the impossible task
and what's the deal with marcus
just how much do you remember about the
john wick series
if john wick has a singular narrative
hook it's that its bloody revenge
mission is spurred by the murder of a
puppy revenge is often a motive in
violent action films making the victim a
poor defenseless pet puts a new spin on
the trope and succeeds in getting
audiences invested in jon's desire for
vengeance what you may have forgotten
however is that the puppy no longer
drives jon's need for revenge by the end
of the film yosef tarasov leads the home
assault that ends with john wick's car
being stolen and his dog being killed
but yosef isn't the film's final
adversary jon successfully kills joseph
partway through the movie and seems
ready to call it quits on his path of
bloody destruction until he's given a
new reason for vengeance would you kill
john wick for two million dollars
after all you were close
yosef's father vigo is the top dog of
the criminal empire john finds himself
up against john used to work for viggo
and the two share mutual respect and
understanding vigo even goes as far as
to discipline his son for acting against
jon after his son is killed viggo takes
his anger out on marcus jon's old mentor
rather than the death of the puppy it's
the murder of marcus that puts john wick
on a second collision course with the
tarasov family
though john wick is an unstoppable
killing machine he isn't entirely
without mercy yes he kills hundreds of
people over the course of the series but
he also lets quite a few people live in
the first film alone jon lets several
people go unscathed before infiltrating
the red circle nightclub jon has a brief
exchange with the door guard francis
it's clear the two know each other are
you here on business sir
great sir francis
why don't you take the night off jon
also lets miss perkins live after she
tries to assassinate him jon even lets
joseph go a decision he comes to regret
jon gets yosef in his sights from across
the room in the red circle but opts to
move in to finish him off up close he's
interrupted and joseph slips away this
is a mistake he doesn't make twice the
next time he has a chance to kill joseph
he takes it before joseph has even
finished speaking jon's merciful side
carries over into the sequels in john
wick chapter 2 jon lets vigo's brother
live after fighting his way through the
factory to retrieve his stolen car he
leaves his blade in cassian's heart
telling him he'll live if he gets to a
hospital in john wick chapter 3 he lets
both of zero's main shinobi fighters
live his gracious tendencies even get
him into trouble in the end when winston
double crosses him aurelio is an auto
mechanic who lends his services to the
continental and runs a chop shop for the
tarasoft crime family when joseph brings
john wick's stolen car into the shop
ariello recognizes it immediately he
refuses to work on the vehicle and
attempts to throw iosef and his buddies
out when they won't leave ariello
punches iosef in the mouth normally
someone wouldn't be able to assault a
mob boss's son and live to tell the tale
but john wick's reputation puts the
events in a different context viggo
understands ariello's actions when the
situation is explained to him and takes
ariello's side over his own sons ariello
makes a brief appearance near the start
of john wick chapter 2 as well though he
doesn't return in chapter 3 the
character is still alive and could
conceivably show up in subsequent
sequels or even in the continental
spin-off series
when jon falls in love with helen the
civilian he needs to leave his career as
an international super assassin behind
the trouble is a life of violent crime
isn't something you can walk away from
so easily since the high table isn't
introduced in the first film it seems as
though viggo is john wick's direct
employer and the man who decides whether
or not he can exit the fold viggo can't
reasonably allow john to walk away so he
devises a plan i gave him an impossible
task
a job no one could have pulled off viggo
is certain john will die carrying it out
but he doesn't the impossible task
proves to be possible for the one and
only john whit and his safe retirement
is secured not many details are known
about the impossible task it has been
alluded to a handful of times throughout
the series but never showcased in any
detail perhaps this suicide mission will
eventually be revealed in the form of a
sequel flashback a prequel or in the
continental spin-off series
by the end of the first movie jon is
gravely wounded and running on fumes
desperate he breaks into a dog pound to
clean the knife wound in his stomach and
staple it shut while there john frees
one of the dogs from the kennel and
takes the poor pup with him if you look
closely at the clipboard attached to the
front of the dog's crate you can see
he's due to be euthanized if jon had not
stepped in this second canine companion
would have shared the first dog's fate
this dog lacks a name and returns in
both sequels he miraculously survives
the house explosion toward the beginning
of john wick chapter 2 and accompanies
jon on his long walk back to the city at
that point the dog is remanded into
charon's care where he remains for much
of john wick chapter 2 and john wick
chapter 3.
is that the dog
he likes you
me
i'm more of a
cat person myself
marcus is majorly involved in the plot
of the first john wick film even so you
may have forgotten about him and his
unique relationship with jon after
watching the sequels there is no mention
whatsoever of marcus in the second and
third films this absence is a little bit
conspicuous given how significant he is
in the first movie marcus's death is so
potent it's what drives jon to kill
viggo marcus can best be described as a
mentor to jon as an older hitman who
showed him the ropes there is a clear
affinity and loyalty between the two men
marcus even attends helen's funeral but
john wick chapter 3 reveals that jon was
trained in a russian orphanage ballet
academy assassin school it's unclear how
marcus fits into this equation exactly
perhaps he was an instructor within that
academy perhaps he and john cross paths
later in life perhaps the series world
building was still being worked out
during the first film's development
whatever the reason these tantalizing
details leave fans with questions about
marcus's place in john's life
when jon goes on his killing spree
through the red circle nightclub the
partying civilians panic and run for
cover on its own this seems perfectly
natural after viewing the sequels
however the crowd's reaction sticks out
throughout john wick chapter 2 and
chapter 3 jon and other assassins
frequently conduct lethal business right
out in the open there the public's
reaction is far more subdued whether
it's a stabbing in grand central station
or a shootout in the middle of a subway
platform people never seem to pay much
mind to the violent happenings around
them in the first john wick however the
crowd does react in terror when faced
with the threat of violent death it
seems likely that this difference in
reaction comes from the franchise's
expanded world building john wick
chapter 2 introduces the bowery king and
his army of homeless agents who populate
new york city's streets this film also
significantly ups the number of
assassins operating in the city and
around the world at times it seems as
though almost everyone in john wick's
world has some connection to the
assassination trait but this is not
apparent in the first film where people
reasonably flee sudden bloody mayhem
are you scared of the boogie man
i'm not
no
but you should be
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite action movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]